now we all know
you love chicken i do
but we're gonna do it's a way that daddy
used to eat it in paris
okay now i'm gonna hold that up okay
season
inside please why is it yellow because
it's a corn fed chicken obviously he's
corn and if you eat lots of corn
turn yellow turn yellow now what are
those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah a little taste
first yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better salt pepper in there as well
please
now
chilies when you hear that noise is that
made
the seeds have come out that's right
take off the tops
we're gonna add the chilis to the
chickpeas in
and then zest the lemon in there please
you love your zest
i love my zest you're absolutely right a
little glug
of olive oil come on holes don't worry
about your nails now
come on baby you can do it now time
you peed off all those wonderful little
buds see
so as we stuff the chicken with the
fresh thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin
now what's that tarragon what's
slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little bit
anna cd
yep so imagine that flavour going into
the chicken
that's going to be delicious now nice
soft butter
in with the tarragon
is that lovely yeah now i want you
gently
to put your fingers through there and
just so we get that butter under there
but i need those small beautiful little
hands
ew what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done i want you
to get a nice handful of butter
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide
and that's how you get all that
wonderful yeah
butter running down and the breasts stay
nice
and moist and like you yeah
put all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they
no here we go good and push down
come on okay now place my lemon in there
right
take your garlic shall wash my hands no
not yet we lay the garlic onto the tray
now onto the garlic
salt pepper make your skin nice and
crispy
and then i'm just going to drizzle some
olive oil that will stop the butter from
burning
and look at that please open them door
thank you
there she goes beautiful good job
thank you really good nice to see holly
get our hands there do i
i think we all agree
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue tower
guaranteed to wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
[Music]
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy peaks
gently fold in ground and chopped
hazelnuts
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
[Music]
top your meringues with more finely
chopped hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes and the trick to
stop them cracking
is to turn the oven off and let them
cool inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool whip the cream until
it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your towel with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love
but be warned they'll all want second
helpings
[Music]
the chickens in the oven and the
desserts sorted now
for a big easy green salad so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
dijon
say a nice little
squeeze of honey love honey
good a little splash of
aged balsamic and this is your favorite
this one isn't it
i just like the it has a nice sweetness
but then it has
a bitterness to it too nice
next to virgin olive oil why do we have
to use a whisk not just a
spoon the purpose of using a whisk
is so it can emulsify and more
importantly you're bringing all the
ingredients together
taste
it's so yummy that is delicious isn't it
a good tip to loosen any vinaigrette and
give it a lighter taste
is add a spot of water now the juice
of a lemon squeeze the lemon in
nice now use some butter lettuce
start placing the salad around the
outside
this one is a la la rosso okay
so we'll put that one on the inside
we're sort of making a nice flower
and you put your heart in it's just like
a
there
that's exactly what i'm trying to do a
nice beautiful
flower now from there
you crisscross your avocado what does
crisscrossing do instead of just
exciting i'll show you now you put your
spoon in there and look that's so cool
got all these nice little bits i want
you to sprinkle those little bits in
here
i'm telling you that first dinner you
cook for your boyfriend it's going to be
extraordinary
that romantic dinner the roast chicken
the beautiful salad
okay yeah to the way your father taught
you and how nice will that be all three
of us sat down eating at the same time
very nice are you gonna do that with
megan all of you
all of you and i'd grab the chicken okay
now look at this beauty
that looks amazing doesn't it right so a
little bit
squeeze all that garlic
down see how soft and beautiful it is
smells amazing
the lemon that we stuffed inside the
chicken
roasted what we do now is just squeeze
all that through
look at that nice
garlic puree i'll tip all my
chickpeas in there
from there some of your vinegar
in now you crush them
and because they're still nice and hot
they absorb all that wonderful garlic
and lemon puree
the rich delicious creamy vinaigrette
the chilis i can guarantee you young
lady
that they are the best the finest
the most delicious chickpeas you've ever
tasted
[Music]
go on then it's yummy right
in now little drizzle
extra virgin olive oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on chickpeas and that is a roast chicken
fit for a kingdom this looks really
yummy
this is my ultimate home-cooked french
dinner
first job my chicken frigge tilly
would you mind helping daddy with the
chicken fricassee please
we're gonna start off with browning
all the chicken off nicely
pan on get that nice and hot what i want
you to do for me first
is to season the chicken with salt and
pepper
please thank you so
that's on one side then we turn the
chicken over so we season it on the
other side
salt good girl and pepper nice
now this is almost like a chicken stew
okay
what's that there
[Music]
um time time good girl what's that one
there
that one's real that's right originally
and because this is quite a rustic
french dish we don't need to chop
everything
so you get the garlic and you just bash
it like that
now smell right so that's nice and hot
put a tablespoon of olive oil in there a
couple of gloves
one two good girl put the chicken in
and you lay away you got that nice and
brown i'm getting good at this
you are skin side down
so we got the color on the skin now i
just want you to cut the mushrooms in
half the belly please
okay these are chestnut mushrooms there
are lots of different kinds
of mushrooms out there there are lots
and lots of different types of mushrooms
which one's your favorite one of my
favorites is the
giro mushroom i like mushrooms that are
a bit bigger than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle
put pesto and cheese in it and then we
bake them ah
so i want you to sprinkle the pancetta
over the chicken please
good girl nice mushrooms
not yet because i'm gonna get some color
on the chicken first
okay and
as that pancetta starts to cook down
it puts a really nice flavor on the
chicken
yeah so we're sort of soaking everything
okay all right garlic in please
good girl just throw them in and i want
you to sprinkle the mushrooms on top of
that
good girl and then there's the rosemary
you can get your fingers like that and
you pull it down
you take it all off hold it
put it down good girl so now you've got
the nice little rosemary sprigs
and we do the same with the thyme now
the thyme flour is a little bit smaller
what different flavors do they give so
the thyme is a little bit sweeter
okay and the rosemary a little bit more
savoury
which ones you like i like them both
because they both get a nice smell
don't they so bay leaf in
i'd like you to put that rosemary and
thyme
in there please lovely sprinkle it over
right i'd like you to stand back now
because we're going to flambe this
i do not want to get those little
slippers caught on fire what are the
names
rampa and judy julia nice
okay great ready yeah
in with a brandy and then just tilt the
pan gently
[Music]
whoa whoa how cool is that
a magical like a cauldron all the cognac
has been
flambe so there's no raw alcohol
anywhere so we've got a really nice
deep rich flavor i'm going to add my
chicken stock
you know rampo likes that not my slipper
rump
for the dog ah rumple the dog well he
likes chicken stock
yes when he's a good boy he gets um he
gets it in his um
with his biscuit it's gone in like wow
really quickly
simmer and reduce the stock for around
10 minutes
now we're gonna cook the most amazing
potatoes
soda potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious
start by slicing the potatoes into
finger whipped pieces
then parboil them for five to six
minutes
when you cook something like rosemary or
thyme or basil
does it slowly let off the flavor into
the bottle
very much so in a hot pan
add a tablespoon of goose fat and saute
the potatoes until they turn golden
and add in shallots garlic rosemary and
thyme
that goes in over top
that goose fat now is starting to fry
the potatoes
you just leave that sat there to
complete my ultimate french dinner
my version of a classic a glorious
lavender creme caramel for dessert
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender to
caster sugar and store
you can also try this trick with vanilla
pods and cinnamon
to bring new subtle flavors to sweets
and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers
and cool now to make a simple custard
gently heat whole milk in a pan until
steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar
until golden and fluffy then gradually
pour the hot milk
into the mix whisking continuously until
the custard is smooth
and creamy to set cook in a water bath
or bamboo
a good tip is to line a roasting tin
with a cloth to stop the ramekins
jiggling around pour your custard
boiling water around the ramekins until
halfway
up the sides then cook in a preheated
oven
for around 30 minutes until set cool in
the fridge
then when you're ready to serve dip the
ramekins in hot water to loosen
the creme caramel
[Music]
ebola lavender clean caramel
[Music]
look at that chicken now so i'm just
gonna
turn the gas right down and put the lid
on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can net out some stuff so i can let
out some steam that's right
now what i'd like to do is to chop daddy
some parsley crunch it up nicely
tuck your fingers in and take your time
[Music]
now my hands have got lots of different
flavors all those wonderful flavors
you could almost be french
sprinkle that on there good girl
nice messy buckle
nice now potatoes
i can tell jack's gonna love this is he
looks the nest doesn't it smells
delicious look at that
i could smell that even before you took
the lid off let's kill my darling
good job by the way thank you i can't
wait for the others to try it i hope
that i
love it this is my ultimate french
dinner
chicken fricassee with sensational
herbie sauteed potatoes
and lavender creme caramel